well you started so well we're so
excited and yeah we're better right
what happened um I think I just got a
bit lost I'm an own kitchen at home I
sort of know where everything is and I
sort of found myself well any other ends
not really know where everything was and
then towards the end of the sort of
right at the time so everything was
prepped and cooked I just didn't have
enough time to get it out very
thoroughly what didn't make it to the
plate the fennel the roasted fennel ding
coming out to that ready
it was literally ready to go over them
at that time i couldnt get the puree out
so couldn't find the little spoons to
get an appeal for help you see here's
what upsets me about you you tantalize
me you draw me in and then bang you wind
me do you know why because this dish
sound is incredible and it's almost like
a chef's dream ingredients beyond belief
and you executed them usefully but
there's nothing on the plate yeah
what happened the last two minutes I
just got a bit fluffy the time we're
announced and then trying to multitask
be a man I know you can chef but I'm not
really good at that
yeah and I'm sorry whatever had some can
multitask we are men you can do it yes
we can I just filed for the evidences
you've got military training we may not
be able to give birth but we can
multitask in your head out the son